well let's take you to the Ukrainian
Capital cave where U.S President Joe
Biden has arrived it's his first visit
to Ukraine since Russia invaded now
almost a year ago
now you're watching pictures from the
Ukrainian capital and there are some
this was just moments ago and I'm not
sure if you can see but in the very back
of the frame there there are two men
walking one of them is Vladimir
zielinski the Ukrainian president in his
military fatigues his traditional
military fatigues and the gentleman in
the black suit next to him that is U.S
President Joe Biden this was a surprise
visit that we're only hearing about now
he was due to go to Warsaw let's speak
to Alan Fisher he joins us live now from
the Polish Capital Alan I believe
President Biden was due there today and
still is but it seems he has made a bit
of a surprise detour now
there was always the suggestion that he
could go to Cave certainly the White
House was not confirming anything at the
end of last week what we do know is that
at 4 15 on Saturday morning a Sunday
morning he boarded a flight coming in
this direction everything was kind of
kept very quiet he got a train into Kiev
now if he followed the example of Tony
blinken the the Secretary of State and
Lloyd Austin the defense secretary when
they traveled to Keith last year they
went by train The Carriage was taken
over by them and the windows were
blanked out Joe Biden has been Keen to
go to Cave when he was here in Poland
exactly a year ago he wanted to make the
journey but at the last minute the
secret service advised that it wasn't
safe they couldn't make sure that he
would be protected fully and so it was
canceled and then his wife went to to
Ukraine on Mother's Day in May last year
so Joe Biden was always Keen to go there
and just in the last few minutes we've
had a statement from the White House
confirming that the president is
actually he has met Vladimir zielinski
he's also announced an additional half a
billion dollars worth of military aid to
Ukraine no new weapons in that later's
batch but what he's saying is they will
provide money for ammunition for
artillery uh Javelin anti-tank missiles
and also howitzers which have been so
successful in helping to push the
Russians back in many parts of Ukraine
and the President also said that he will
be announcing additional sanctions in
the coming days he's due to meet with
the Polish president uh here on Tuesday
he Wars due to leave Washington tonight
in the next few hours in fact but
obviously here in the region already and
then on Wednesday he will meet members
of NATO who represent the nine countries
of the Eastern flank of NATO here in
Warsaw as well the intention always was
that on Tuesday here in Warsaw he would
make a significant speech to Mark at the
one year anniversary of the war he of
course has said that the United States
has played a leading part in helping
Ukraine protect their democracy and in
Ukraine in the last few minutes he has
said that the U.S is there to stay and
that has no intentions of leaving
Ukraine or leaving the Ukrainian people
those comments coming of course as we're
seeing a number of voices in the
Republican Party by no means the
majority the Republican Party in the
United States saying that they are
concerned about the amount of money that
is being
funneled to Ukraine to help in their
battle against Moscow but Joe Biden
making it absolutely clear it is not his
intention of America's intention to walk
away from the commitment that they've
given to Ukraine and the Ukrainian
people indeed a very busy trip there for
Joe Biden Alan Fisher on the ground for
us in the Polish Capital Warsaw we'll
leave it there for now thank you very
much Alan we can now go to Abdul Hamid
she joins us live from the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev the Optics here must be
exactly what the ukrainians have been
hoping for
well certainly I think many ukrainians
are quite surprised by this unannounced
visit I have to say that we were
actually out and about filming we did
hear the air Sirens Blair throughout the
city and actually we're still on the
alert as we speak now and then we
noticed that something was up because
the street was empty and they were sort
of policemen posted we saw a small
motorcade we didn't make much of it we
thought there was a high level visit
somehow but we did not think it would
have been the U.S President Joe Biden
now he has been spotted not very far
away from here at the michelasquez
Cathedral working with President
zelenski I think many ukrainians will be
very happy to know about this as the new
spreads there is a bit of anxiety in the
air as we approached the one year
anniversary of the beginning of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine people were
also apprehensive because the Russian
President Vladimir Putin is supposed to
give a speech on Tuesday a backtrack to
last year on the 22nd of November
Vladimir Putin gave a speech and two
days later there was a full-scale
Invasion people here worried that
something could be up that the Russians
could be trying to do something to mark
their way this one year anniversary so
certainly having the U.S president here
in the capital
showing support pledging more military
aid pledging more military package and
also sanctions is something that is
going to be very welcomed among
Ukrainian not only president zielinski
live for us in the Ukrainian capital
thank you so much hotter well meanwhile
EU foreign ministers are currently
meeting in Brussels to discuss the war
in Ukraine this also comes a day after
the United States warned China not to
give weapons to Russia well for more on
all of this let's speak to our
diplomatic editor James Bays he is in
Brussels for us James obviously this
trip that Biden has decided to take is
happening right as the EU ministers are
meeting it's really quite the symbolic
moment
foreign
a very very important moment yes the
ministers are actually inside the
building
um the foreign Ministers of the European
Union the moldovan foreign minister is
about to join them he's not a member of
the EU he's currently talking to
reporters
um they clearly are not seeing the
pictures that we're seeing of President
Biden on the streets with President
zielinski uh one year on or very nearly
one year old into the War I think this
shows a picture of defiance by the
Ukrainian president uh remember back at
the beginning of the war
um when the Russians invaded almost a
year ago many thought that Kiev was
going to fall many thought that
President zielinski would end up in a
Russian jail or killed that that is how
seriously people felt that the uh that
things were going to go in Russia's
Direction and The might of the Russian
army would Prevail well clearly that's
not the way it was worked and you've got
now the U.S president showing his
solidarity almost one year on and lots
of debate here going on about how the US
and the rest of the Western Alliance can
continue to support Ukraine uh one year
on we hear that that one of the problems
and I'm sure this is something that
president zielinski is going to be
mentioning to President Biden as they
speak there in Kiev is the problem of
rearmament yes Ukraine wants all sorts
of other things in addition to now tanks
it's getting from the West including
fighter jets but the more imminent
problem is that that artillery that is
holding back the Russians the artillery
shells are being used by the ukrainians
faster than they can be made in the
factories and so there is a real real
problem there and we're hearing that
there's going to be quite an urgent
meeting taking place here in Brussels at
NATO headquarters in the next 24 hours
with the Ukrainian foreign minister with
the NATO Secretary General with the
European Union's High representative of
Foreign Affairs to try and bang heads
together and get more armaments get more
weapons uh to to the front lines
particularly in eastern Ukraine James
you were just in Munich at the security
conference there and we were hearing
from leaders that they do expect this
war to continue potentially quite long
term do you get the sense that that's
also on the table there that they're
making preparations amongst EU foreign
ministers for that to be the case
yeah the word is it's going to be a long
war and we need to give Ukraine whatever
it wants but of course there is caveat
to that Ukraine keeps asking for things
and the EU and NATO leaders discuss it
and in most cases we've seen it slowly
ramped up the aid and now now tanks are
going to Ukraine but it always takes a
fair bit of delay and a fair bit of
discussion both around the NATO table
and here at the European Union but for
now I think yes the support is there but
I think it's worth bearing in mind that
you're seeing now president zolenski
you're seeing President Biden both there
for this very important trip very
symbolic trip to Kiev but remember the
U.S election timetable because President
Biden has got now
um just a couple of years left in office
and we've got a presidential election
coming up in the United States and that
might see a return of President Donald
Trump or a trumpian type president now
would they want to continue the current
policy towards Ukraine already now that
the Republicans have the control of the
House of Representatives we're hearing
words from Republicans like no more
blank checks for Ukraine so I think
while the Europeans say they're
determined and they say this is
absolutely key for the future of
European diplomacy and many of the
states that are right next to Russia the
border Russia feel that they you know if
this if this war isn't won by Ukraine
then potentially they could be next but
of course there's the U.S component and
the U.S political component and as
you're aware there is quite an
isolationist element within the U.S
political system
James Bay is their diplomatic editor at
that EU foreign Minister's meeting for
us in Brussels thank you very much James